E
LODOWNPA CAD-SNON W T
AYOD.
♪
ANR:UNNOCESH "WAGTINONRN JOU"AL
UENTCOIN
FFERRLN SOMOEYOI DS  TNGHI
IE
N ERFFSORLMOEYE , TH OTHAUOR
F
IA"C,FK JECHE T STRE
INSAASSSIOATNIL F,"
."
YOANTHK JOFOU R USINING
TALK AOUUTBO Y AWOR RKONSOS ME
H
ARREO SEESCHHE T EOFNTVES
JFM'S
ERRD.
MYJFK ROAC BKGUN I--S
GUT:ESY  MOUCKBAGR INDSBOUT
D K JFANALFIOFCINGDUS RIHE T
60' 'S,OTN HESCTAS W -
MEJAETANS GL T WONASHE CEFF O
UNCOELRITENTEGELINCE T  ATHACI
95OMFR 1.194-74
VEI HA A B AAPGRHYIMUTBO H
.
I AND VEHA ACOOR FTHNGMIOO B
KH
YSTE OR OARRIF CHN NID XODAN
DCHRIAREL H I TM,HEEC DTSIRRTO
TOFHEIA C
OFFIFRALCIS OMHE '95 10'SND A
19S''WEHE TY  F ARELL
ENS
ANDOL INVDVE IEVTHN E TSENF O
6319.
SSASSAN ATINIORPEE, S ITE WRINDY
ABASTHT E ATSSSAIN TN IOIN
HE
CONT TT EXOF. CHEIA
STHO: WT HAISNTORMPTAOR F
S EWVIERER UTONDAND  T
HEPO
YTISIONE? TOUAK
T:GUESNO D IO E WRT IT
OUABT
PICONSCYRAOR THES,IETE W IRI
ABHEWHT ETVEHE T ESNTF  O6319
S LOOKO KELI TACIID INSS.ER
THTH IISS Y STE ORWENO K
A NOT THORSTY LD CATOUOWE  BKN
N
96IN 1
TBU H T DOWIDENSEHE MEE WT
ENHAPP IEDN DLAALS,HA W
PPENH  WEDITVEE THINIOIGSTAT
N
WWHATINSEE E HRLL A TRI SEETO
S
TISHE IA TH ONELOAN M A
NA
NG AMELOND AD IL KLEETH
ENESPRIDNOFOT R  R
SOEAN.
ONONEMETHF E D ACN TEHAKELI T
A
CTHS EE.AS
, THRAERCTEYTH AHT LEDIG
EYRVAL OSWA WAD S IVNSSEITLYHA
EMA
ERTT,HO WSE KGEWLNOED
ONTIS, W ANDNOSEHO K BEDWLGE
H
HACIE A E TOD  BLDHESE CLO.LY
E ATWH WISW SATHEE WK IS
A
ESPROCLSTS IL UNGOLNFDICITH, E
STIDI HLLOLNGLYLO CSEINER CTA
INN ATRMIOKEOUABT EDNNY''
ASIOINSSAT
BREKSOO A DD IGESNEN  OTOPE
H
IS AND SAT, AYWHID DHE T
ASIOINSSAT LLON OK TE IKTO
HI
TSA I
EL
STHO:ITHE WN  TOM CESO T
ATFOINRMU N IOYOLKTA A
UTBO,
E THERRES WAA OFASLEE UM DOCTSEN
BYHE TNAAT NIOIVARL CH
ES
CERE
LYNT.
ATALKHAUTBO TPUANT D
INTO
PEPERSIVCTEHAHA WT SEE B
HD
HEBY THI ARCNCS VECO TNIERNG
HF
SSASK SAN.ATINIO
GUT: LTASK, WEE49 11
ENOC DUM
H
ATINON CTAED RNSCTEAIO
MATEITD ,RITEALER WEEA RELDSE
L  FINULE R FOTHRSFITIM T
E.14
00UM DOCELTSEN ROEDAT T
K'EDNNY'SAS ASIOINSSATN R
AN
CORE TIONNU HAVREAD
ACS.ON
SO,T E  WGOSS TN 10HEOF%  T
OUGNDTAINUM DOCASTSEN LT
.
AL, IMPIST  I TTAORNT
NDRSDETAYOHE WN K THU INOUT
ATTHSEEL REAARWH, Y WEE
INLEREASRDREG CO
2, 1IN99ESON CGRS PE D SETHKJF
S CORERDT.AC
ATHA TT POLNTOI, TOERIV S
D
JUSTADE EMOA VI ANDCO SDRE
IINPOTSPUBLNI OPI
BONY
TIPOIN T ONGUTY  VHEERUETR
T
3THATYEARAFTE
THR E
ASATSSSAINLMN,IO AL T OSAL
E
GONTRNVEMES''S CORERD
TONE
ECSUBJ CWET REIESSLAIF
E STONTRT PUA ATLEAIR NDHE T E
OFIE MISOVND AAI STE WD,RI
YOU F  IYOJEOBCT
HI TS.
TOCAPI WHIL LLND IASNUITEDAT W
ILMA, AINSKG, W DOE'S'
THE
RNGOVEELNTME RHESEEA T
ATFOINRMN?IO
SSNGCOREEDSH AAMDONT IO EG INTH
TGHRIT
NGHI.
D ANCOE THRETS RDAC SDAIE  WLLWI
E LEREASL ALOFFK JS''S,CORERDE W
LELLWI CAR THEOR RECMAAND D
KH
NS TISRA TREPANTO EDYRYVEBO
.
W WL T ANALCOK JFRE BS RDTO
E
ICPUBL
AT CEYRERO AED PO SSCE T
DO
ATTH.
CTHEY SATREEDNGETOMHIDAL CLE
THINSAASSSREIOATN RERDCOS EWVI
ARBOD, APEINN DEBOENNDT DED ARMA
UPLICIF VIANER EXP.TS
ENEYTH WACTOT  ERNGOH VENTME
AENAGCYNDAI SW  SD,HO YOU
KJFOR REC W, DSWEVIL ILREM TEWHE
FOFIASCLSIOR IEDNF ATIMAON
NH
E  MENAKEMTHUBLI
1 TINHE0'9'T  TS,HAT  WISHAEYTH
DID.
LA DEYECD IFSSIEHAREMO T
N30
000,0EC RDSOR RELOEDAT T
KEY'E'SSASS SAN,ATINIO
5MI
IOLLN.AG PES
TH BAS W AP  SIGTEDRWFOAR
N
S TERMOFOM CGETPLINTO HIS
CL
RDRECOFKOFS  'ASSAIOINSSAT
O
O :ST G
EAAHD.
T:GUES
EA YH.
T,BU THE VEW LAGAHE TIEGE ANCS,
R
Y ARIMILE CIAND F,BIUT B
GOMENTGENCES IETH TIG RHT
CHOTHLD ITAERINTIORNFMAON
R
WHATESON CGR WSAS IDER AASFT5 2
ARYERY ES,VEMUINTHG MA BSTE
DU
ICBL.
W E THLA ISSPAEDN99 1 25 ARS
TELAOB OR,CT OERF7, 201HE T
ONESQUTITOAM CE DERE PSI
NT
UMTR
DICIE A , CTREORKEMIOM PO,PE
E IDSA WNNCAOTEL RSEEA
HI TS
ETSECR WIOATN,VEE  T IKEO EP
:STMAF  II YRUNT IERME, PTSO
OFSEHO CS,CEONRN TREY HEWE
BE NE USOFL IOATNATYCUSERI
.WS
ATYO DO K THU INTHOUABT
ANENRG AUM
T:ESN  WHEE U YOSESATWH I
LDTHWIHEWIYO, U LL.AU LGH
ITBEIL WL SHI TNG LEE,IK WAD H
NTELGENCTIREE LA
SHOP
WITH B THETIRISHER GOVENT.
WAHA TT OFONS E HIHE T TSNG
EDLEREASHI TS
EE WK.
WE HIN AADN ENLLTEIG
TIRELASHONIPITH ETI BRI.SH
NOW, IS AT AIT NSENAIOL
RY
ETSECR TTHAHE THA.S U.
ENLLTEIGAT RCEELITNSIO WSIN
HGR
ITT EABRN?AI
SATTH I PERPORESTS,OU BT TUTHA
ISD  KHEINNG TOFHIOINGN,
VELDWI OSICLR ASONCAFITI
ONNATIUR SALECYITAS HIV GEN
S
JUTHE ATIFSTICUTN,IO BYOHE WN
O
WH AOKT ATTUS  IACLYAL
LDTHWIHES IT,  IRYVEYAR REL
SOTHINTHG AT ISSER  ORITOS
VEE THLEATOFL  NNAIOLEC S
.
UM,N  IDOESTHE S MECUNTARERTHE
E
MENAS ORMINF FOTS.
ATHIST HE T MD INOFLERATIA
THREAS W PYOUVISLELIT WHH
REWET  ANGAL TKIBO AUTSVE ENTD,U
AT HD PEAPNE50OUABT
R  0
SYEAR A.GO
5 WITASS YE8 ARATO AGTHASFK J W
ASEDINSSAT
, SOTIE THNAECALON SVAITURY ELU
I TOFHETIORNFMAHH WONITD,EL IN
O
ES CSTAS MT  IIS.IMINAL
OREX NON.TEISNT
HO: LIN METE TEVIUR O CLEALRS
HETOIN TRSON CVE
IOATN.
YOU LLN CACAS U A7420T 2-808-00
R THE INASHE T ERNTEND A
L NTCERAONMETI Z.ES
8-2-20740180HOOR F TTH ISEN
EMO
TAUNINND AACIF TIMS.ZOE NE
TEAT UXTS 4802 2-700-83.
YOU GOTOAC BK  TTHA D
IN,
BEOCTOR6, 2 W01 27, GN HEITS
HE T TDMMPRU AATISINTRTN,IO I
GEDEXT EEND,HY W
T:ESE  HT IDSA I BD HATO
EWI
FHETHLDTH AORNOR FEROU Y
.
HE GE THANCIE A ANFBD I
DOT
ENR HEAGNOESCI AOUERTH F
RYE
SS AROF.REECCY
SOATTH KTHKEICD TIQUE ES
O
IDPRESDET ENBINOC IN OFBETOR
AND ATHINGA, ANCIE A
FBD I
EDFAILETO  TMEHE DDLIN
PRTHE TIDESENNCNN AOUEDHATHE T
AGOUESCI CTI CLDON
E NUTO
WITHLD ML,ERATIA BY  TUTHEDHA
DTOO- - H ADELTO DERIV
SOG.THMEIN
WLASTEK,EE W 1 GOTTH O0%F
00,0 DTSUMOCENSTHA TT VEL ILHA5
RE A,IOCTNSEA LNGVI 1
00,
H WHICPPE ARSUO EDOS T
BERE
AASLEEDFREA YR . NOMOW
FR IKLANY,T O  DNOELIBEEV
I.
HTHEYOWE AVBLTHE ADLI
NETW
E.IC
TD ANONRD THEHIIM TED,RO AUN
THUSIV GE F 0% 1 OHEATWH TAW L
ESQUREIR
WANTEYO  TOBAWHE T LDIAOETNO
EEEYTH KPDI EVA
TNGHE
REENIRQUEMEY, TSTHDOAV HE
T
ETHREIM T.ES
ASO ISUNOM T WI WREE R ELLVE
SEREESTHE
RDCOS.
T ACRDINHETOG  TTHAW L,
ER
OSSUE PP TEDOE RE AASLEED
YERO FM
OW N.
ITHATBITHS E GREIC PTU
E HEYAVL  BIL-- HEAVLO B.TH
E
LIDEADCE TNEWI
AN OMOD STE THF ESS CORERDVEHA
EN SN BE
REFO.
T NOOFLOA T ISUR SPR IESNER H
ABPROBT, LYOUOSF  OTH
14E 1
DOS,MECUNTOFOS MT  AHI WCH
R WE
TOMHEIA COF90, 0 HE T
SHAVENEEM  THE FFOBERE
TE
MOSTAR P
A CPLE M  TOFHEO EMSE T
N
NRETILY.EW
AE OU CPL D FOFBIUMEN.
BUT TOR IHEMPNT TNG ITOS
ACEPST BKND A L TK OOAT
BG
URPICTE, R
HTIG?
H WHICAT, ISWHWEAV HE EDEA LRN
NCE E DOS MECUNTGABENO T
NTMECO IRETHO E
RDCO?
W,NOPEOM SE AYLEOP S IHE TRENOS
GOKSMIN. GUN
EYD ANTH TRI TEDENO D T
HECO
TIERNVSARE TONHE
ATTHOOOT N LNGKI AT,T' 'S
WDIOINGEH ITTHOR RECL TDSEL
US
LEAV HE OFNEARD FFHE T O
L
Y STORNEATTH OAMAN M CGALE ON
ANDIL KE D LETHENESPRID
ANTD
HEANOTKIGUR Y EDLLT  THADN MAAN
, ITNOICOL PITS I TVEOLD,THA
ATPLEXANS N IOWACRVENER ,IBEDLE
ANGOHAD S ESENTT LIBCRS ED
LEOV
ERE. TIM
COUP THI HS NGWEEAVRN LEA
D
ESINCHE99ID M-1S'0'HEOMFR T
NES,CORERD ULL RH,EADSTY AN
T.OU
E,ON THETO ST  TRYHAISTH M,AN
RVE LEHAAL OEYSWE  CD,AMT OF
ERWHEE ND A WT D DINOOWKN
YTHI HBO AUTAT, IMTHS I
NSNO
SEEN.
CTHEYIANE KW A ALLIMUTBO H
TH B HEYADLLN EEFOHIINOWG FOR
RS YUREA
THIT MEYONLLEDOR ASF  OHI
S.TIACON
THE DEATSTE NTRTPAMEOFTH, E CEFI
AL NOFAVEL INTE,GELINCHE
MAPS CNEORH WH, IC WWAOSLD
AS
INTHAL, L RMINE FOABIOATN TOU
WALDEN WT TOHE T
CONTTEUNRINCLIELGEE SRUFFTA,
NY
IAM JES AALNGLS.
ATAI LKUTBOHI TS IOOMYN  B
K,T
ST GHEHO
'I'LYSIS MPRUOT N TEUTERNOF WH
SALDOSY WATHHO ST EDERE PSI.NT
OTAMI  NHEUR SE BUID D, HESAT Y
DI
FACTEMAINO WNSE W KWNOOP T
CIIC OFFLSIA, VNIY ERSE
ORUN
ERRCDEOVPE OS TIRAONFICE,
IWERED ORNFMEOUABTAL OSW'D'
POHIS LTILICAIE BELD , FSANENEV
SHI CTACTWITHLIRA BZI
IGRENSGE ANTER WE KO WNNO TPTOO
FIA CIOFT RSCE AXSIEEKSEEF BOR
KES Y EDWA.LLKIED
ANENENWH KASDYNE WD IL KLEDAN
WALDRRESHED,TE TIA C
PRD ENETDEIDEYTH DNOOT N K
WAN
AHIYTNGIMUTBO H
ATTHRE P WNSTEE,NODIE D
KW
ANYTNG AHAUTBO TT,  GUY
W
TKNOWATT HATHAS W A L.IE
ASIT W F L AIEEM ROTH.TA SRT
THATIN LCOHAE S D INNTUES TTOHI
DA
LYREAL WWH, ATNELEE ARRO FMHE T
LEASLASTEE WK,TH IS
E
L STILG LDHOINHECKBA T
HO E
Y.STOR
HO:STHA WE LS CVEALOUOR F Y
.
LPRAIN NOR Y
K.
OUFOR RUEST
KTHAN F YOULI CORAL.NG
HEGO A.AD
:LLCAER T G IOTUEEEHR Q
IOS
THFOR T.GUE ES
'I'ELL B B
EFRI.
ETHST FIRNE O WWEOTEREV GN A
FSWANER WORHY OWAALSWD EDIT
KATIUNL T I NDGOTRWNDO ST.
HE A HADLE CART. SHO
THE  QCOSENDNSTUEIO I
NEUECQLIEN KDYNE, IFOU Y,JA
K
HEAT T CHO PNE,SELOLER HE
HD
IGIS RFR IHTN  TT ONOF
T'IDESE'SD, HEA SO  SITMSEER
ILIKEHEF  W SHOFROMDEH BIN
ITLD WHEOUV''
EE BN
SSASSA.ATINED
YIFCH WOUATILHE T FMSE CLO,LY
LEHIS UL SFTHOUNR DEBOFS CEOF
THF CKBA OE SE CUS
ON.
,O  SRE IHES LYAL F.ORLOED
IHA T YNKOU
T:ESD GOO QN.STUEIO
IFAL OSWINWAD S HE T SLOTHIX F
, NDWIOW HHEADN  A SSIEAER
S
TOE THMOAPADRCE EDOAPRCHS A
OPSEPOD T IWHO ENGOWAT S GIN
.AWAY
INYEHE T ESTNWIESES T OMOTINY
FE
LEPEE OPET  ATHCE S,NEE W
ATHATF OT L O TOPPELE
UGHT
WAERTHE IRGUS NF DFRE OMFERE
IOREDICT.NS
ERMYSTCALRGHS  IRIIS IT,T
IFISHA TT HE T ITIORNFMAAT, ONTH
OS A WLDASINCTG, LO ANEY
DIT''OT SHEHOLI EAR?ER
CKJAIEDYEN KNES''ONSIPOTIGUR DIN
TH ANAASSSSISHONTI, HEISE  T
CLEWT ESEY TNEITSS
WHO AT
ENHAPP.ED
NOW,AC JNNE KIKEVEY EDNE
LIBEEDEV THEFF OSTIAICL ATY ORTH
ONONN MAALEDIL KLE
THE
IDPREST.EN
SHEVBEE LIEDHE TDERE PSI
S
EDKILLS Y  BHIICMEDOSTMI ENE.ES
D E SHANBBBOY KNEENDY CDVEONYE
THGEES MSA
ISTHMES  ISOWEINTHG
AV HE
ARLENCD NESIE 1 THE0'9'KI JS,AC
E
ANEDNNY Y BOD BBY NNKEEDLDTO A
, IEFRND GO WHISO NGOI TETH
UVISOETONNIN I 1TE3 96AF
TE
IDPRESST ENWALE KILY  TD,HE
,
IHEREAS GEES MSAE O  TTHSADLEER
OFIE SHEOVT, NI UONISERTHE
LKSW OS D ALWAUNCOA MMT.IS
WENO DO STPUT T  TK OCINT.HA
IE BWEEL THEDERE PSI
WNS
EDKILLMEY  BDOIC E.MINEES
BOEDKEY NNSAIDIF INEG RAI
THENESPRID ICY WNTL ILCOUEIN
MYTH BRO'E'CIPOS LI.ES
EYTHA EN ST RIRYVE F
DLENY
AGMESSEO  TVIE THSOET
GONTRNVEME,AY SE G,IN W
NT
BUYHI TSIN BUSOUS ESABOSWA
A INBEG ISMMCOUNTR  OETH
ENESPRIDKIWAT S Y EDLL B
MMCO WISUNT,EVBEE LIEE  HSWA
BLLKIEDSTDOY MEIC ENEES.
TH SAS W AONTRG BIE
NNY BBKELDY EDHEBEHA TT EFLIO
E R FOTHF STRE OIFSHI L
EELHA.
:STORN  IGEICA,GI M
LLCA:ERD  GOOG.RNMOIN
I VES WAFI OEA YRSLDHE WN T
ENPPEDND AS T  IWA/1NEMI 9UP1 SA
TIL  AODLTDUHO
THE HEDAY AS W ATESIASNA
THENHEHE WN AS W BURD,IET  ILDTO
--QU MY  ITIESONS,THYOF U KINP
A E THCIIVS WAPRT TOY  ISO
ED W D- NGOI - WWAOSLD
INDOYO DG,O K THU INHEOTREEO PPL
INER GHEOVMIENNMT T'G'WN KVENO
AL?
KTHAN
OU Y.
T:GUES VODY ERGOUE QIOSTN.
S I WAEAVEFI YRS O ALSATWIO N
HA,ENPPED SOMWEO  CHITOE  T
SWI
S TTHHEPEE AMEX.ENRICE
IEM RSIBEEMR ARINTTG
NDOUA
K-BLACITD-ANWHEV, T AND I
NW
THSOMEG G INBIPPD HAHA
EDEN.
ATTHAS W. ALL
AER VYD  GOOONESQUTI DWH, AT
THE OWA CIKNBO A H LUTEEECLOFVEY
LDOSWA?
ERTHA WAE S OFOUGRP OP T
FIOFALCIS,SAS  AI E , IDTH
F
PEOF OSTIRAONTH IN ERWEE ST
N
HERESPMIHECHTH, E F OF
NSATERIOXIN  IMECO CIT
E
STASSIT ANTOEROU CNTIGTEINLLCEEN
JASNG ATON,HE TTASS AIS
O
ARRICHESHOD LM, ALLHEE PPL
IWEREDORNFME AUTBO OAL'D'
MEMOVEX S NTSIBEEKWES HEREFO T
SSASSAN.ATINIO
WHHEID D TYW? KNO
S ISTH IF RTPA OOPY WHPELL SLETI
TWANTHE R TT ESOFHETO S,RY
E CABEUSNO DWEO  AHAT VE
OOD
ANEXPL
IOATN.
ETH C N HIAASXPEREV E.INLAED
I HATE OPTHE EO PPLO LLWI G
TOH
CIE AND A, ASKOW NWEHA TT
HAOFOS MT HE T R, ORECDS
F
TH,EM DE S OETHVEA CIHAN A
ATPLEXANR N IOFO MY WHSOPY ANTO
OFALCISNE KT ABW OUN E THMAOWH
EDPPSUOSLE KLYILD T PREDENT
ANT D DINODONY A
INTHG.
IWHATTHS EXP EONNALATI
.WE
T O  DNO GVEHA A
OO
EXANATN.IO
S ATTH IOPY WHPE S ALERELLTI
STTEINRE.ED
STHO:GR CONOKS ESTOHI TS ON
DU W TNGHEREARNMI COM
IO.
WHYO DATO K THU INTHOUABT EOS
SINCCOLUS?ON
GUT:ES IOPWAT S G ATERINAT
E
Y MERCOFIAHE T C TSO,  IHENKHI T
COISSI N DONIDOTAV HE A
ES
LLTO AE F  OTHATFOINRMD N IOAN
I
INTH WTHK EYSLE ERMITH BEDY
E
CIA.
NI DOHI TKN, NKI .OW
HEON T L DAYVE HEEARLDOSY WA
S
STARREOP, EDPED, SLEAIUO  DYO
HAINNY ATHHIONG  T, GSUY TSHI
RMFOERIN MAREHO H LIV
N
SOTHE ETVI?NI UON
E THIDA CISAAVWE,  HNDA E HALFU
OF DTSUMOCEN RFI, VE AORECDSUTBO
M.HI
A PEWSNEPAPICLR IPNG FND A A
ET
INR HETH.GS
WTHAT S TASHERYTO OMBNON VE
EE
N I3, 196IAHE T CAI SWED
RFIVE.ORECDS
ASATTH W A L.IE
RRE THWAMI CENOMFOIOSSN TD UNOU
THIAHE T CTHAD H OOR REREC,DS
Y  TSOHEACNTWE BSKTOK  A
HEM
FOR TM.HE
KS W10EEAT L,ER 10EE WE, KSTH
CITEDM AITD, NO,D E  WDITNO
NLVEHA OFIY VE DTSUMOCENADWE,  H
42TSUMOCENN OIM H,HA T
WE
ECCOLLERD TEOVOUHE T C
E RF
YFOUR
RSEA.
ETHIA CYEP DUTEC DIRICR,TO RRDHA
LMES
D  TOLMME THCO TSIISONTHA
FOE THINN ATRMIOADEYTH HN O
WAOSLD WASNI "MI
L.MA"
T, FINACEWHE T NERIS H P
NAL
,LIFEIS HICOL PITTHANS D E WEYER
RESG INHIL, MAIISHA TT OW H
Y OSCLEL WASCH WAT.ED
HEEREVYWWE HREE E , NTTHSA CIWA
UPOUD TEABT HISOV M,ENEMTS
G.DOIN L WAS WINIVG, WT HAHE
A E THCISWA WRMINL-FO.
THEDAT WCHHELL A TD AL WLEMECO
ROCKBA FSOTHM E E VUSID U
O,
O GO T GXATES,EWTOO  NNSRL OEA
.
WHE MT ENTOICEXO
IT CY.
THKNCIE A UT AEWBO
HA TT.
E  CHEAMHECKBA, IVAS W L
GN
XATE
CITHE INWAA S  TRMFOEDET HALE
HAAL OEYSWDAS W ISTEN XAN
MBNOVE 1 1ER5,3.96
ATTHS''CHW HOMUKNHE TY UT AEWBO
M.HI
AFPRTHR E T IDESENLLS WAKI,ED
ANASHED  WTERR AESN TD,HE
EDKILLCITH, E EDPLA AYUM DB
D
, SAIDNO DWEO TANNO KW
HIG
TABOU TY.S HIGU
LLSIBACA WWHY ATD FOE UNSTT OULA
WES IARHE TY LSTE ILYI L.NG
POE ONIMTHANRTT D G INDI
PN
WLASTK.EE
CAGEI T SLL ONCU1 49DO
NTS
COUTNGMI OHEIS,  TMO ARE SNGKI
N GUINRE THE
YOUT AN CNO HISRICA
OARSECHWSA N NE
PEPAR
LIDEADN,NE O AN IERNE
NEADDELIOEIT,  DNOS TOR W
THAU VED SPO ENITMETI WHT. IYO
BUINE ONTHS JUG MP MT OUAT
VED ANHAONOT N GUGTHE RO
ALL
THRDREE CO BYES T,M IUT A
EONNG THIISHA TT TAMP IOR
O
RSUNDEND II BETHEVLIE ATOW N
THSSRE P-ATISIASNAE, ONTH C'I'
R
SSASE-SAN ATINION LEFI OELE
ORVHAEYALSWDL , ALETH
RMINFOTHIOATN LE CEYOLNEDCT O
OMM HIFR95 19VEO  TNO0 ERMB 2
OS, 63THMEDOE CUVES NTHA
N
ASDECLFIEDNUL FL, T FOR
HEI
MET RSTI
THOUK INABT TT.HA
LASTDIEE WK AVWED  HAE  A OYNL
OFALL  RHO TSE.ORECDSOP CY O
, SOOEATWH DTHS AT
EA MN?
DIWHY AKITD  TEA58E  YRSO
ASDECL TFISIEDE FHEILEN  OLE
HAAL OEYSWD
?
THATA  IS UEODGO QANIOSTN
E
JTHATFKRCES REARSHEIL WLIN BEG
TOAN TRYO ERSW
OW N.
O WE DVET NOHAPLN  AEXNATANIO
FRHE TIA C ATH, EYLL SRETI
PLGUM D
DAN SITLLTI WNGOLHHDIDSEC ROR
SOCEE  WFAPRHI TS OFLEOBM  C A.
A
ATTHS  DOENTT NOWAEYO  TOB
ETH L,AW H AND P NASOTDVIRODE
ALCOE THREUTS,RD BEE  WAR
BETOINNNG OET G T TPL CHEOME
HI RICORALOFORECD DYEN KNE''
SAIOINSSATN,ND AISHA TT N A
ANPOIMRT.STT EP
:HOSTAN WTAKEERNO ATH
?
GO AAD.
CA:ERES, ODGO MOR
NGNI.
IY EA RLLIAPRAPECR YTEOU
JOICLINASTORKE. HER
VEHAOU YTHEE SN EROLE IVNE STO
JFITEV RIS?ED
EAGRRAPRT OG
ESGUT: I W IASEWERNTVI IEDN
.
S,YE ISEAV HE
IENT.
:LLCAER VODY ERGO
I AYSTMU SMYHA TT ONAK TE
S
LDHOG INIS,  PEOE STTAR
G LKTAINNOOUABT S DYBO I
OVE
LTHE,AWETOU Y BLIR TEBEEEV
ERTHES. I
DAN WEER WEDWAE RN,F  OIT A
NDF
INGOK T ROHE T CS HASSIROF I
DI HENE GINOD T  S AVEIR
T
UBIN CA, C THE N WIAASOTPY HAP
E
OIAS W GCU TNGO THEIBUDG
3BO AUT,0%TE W HAN
TOD EY
TESHATECITR  BHESEAU T TWEY RE
, RFWEUL OTIACNG OSIUTDE
E
LAW.
AN ATHD EYLL SRETI TOI DNGTHA
DATOY.
HAON TISCOT MM--HE ONSI.NEOR
CAI ELOTNN BHEVEIE TY D PUT
S
RE TONHE
GUTHE  GTHY ATRES ETFID,E HND E
P
OEI BNGTHN EOM CN.SSMIIO
THE S  ION W TOFHETRDEIES
DESE  H IAVEEEREV S
IFOU Y TAT WCHIE MHEOVGOM CIN
WIOWEE S HY RE CEPHE
IS.
OMBOTT TIN LE,HE T CIAKOOUT O
THENESPRIDNOANT D ASDYBO H
ABEENABOUCCNT I FLEOR
E THAMOTSH C TFRE OMHERO F.NT
WOPPELENNT ENRUG
UT O.
STHO:LLE  WWI T LHE
UE GT
ANSW.
KTHAN
OU Y.
T:GUES YH,EA M AFTTHON A
EDKENNS'Y'INSAASSS FIOATN,ER
R
IDPRESRRT ENHAMA TYRU 3 TN,HED
PRT,IDESEN ARO WTENRIDI ETOAL IN
H
H ICHE CFOLEALD THE
N ITOLIO C TOFHE.IA
NOW,MA TRUDIDOT NABAL TK TOU
K'J'SSASS SAN ATINIO
TINHE
MNCOLU, A HE VER LYBLPUIC
NKLIED H OPIO ONNI TY'NNKEED
'S
SSASSAN,ATINIO T BUTS REHE I
TUBT THA
MA TRUS'N'ORLLCA FHE T
IOOLABITHEOFN  TASIA C W
ESCTRE RNSPOE T
THO EADI
SSASSAN ATINIONE KOFEN.DY
Y HARR KUMTRANREW NEMO TBO AUT
I
THA ANDYNY ABO,E  HE S WATHEON
IGATTH S ID NEITISO NTEXNCTEEN I
LE4719, AYMET  SUC REL.NTTALY
IN HLLIAY,WAE S AINGAST T
HER
OTIEAONNTA F CELRA
INTECEIGLLENY.GE ANCCE P AEAMETI
AIHE SDO WD,E ANOT N WT
AN
ICAMERTA GANESPO.
CAUS ATIEA PCERE SMEEC
TIN
ENLLTEIGNC ACEGEYEWE  HVI
S
REA THTH TATO CRDEE MOIC
PRS.ES
TWORS YEA, AT LERLDE THCOSAR W I
HEG UP, TWAMARUN
S NTA
CESOURFOF  OINATIOAND
WSLO THERE COFIOATN HE TIA CHEAL
,
S SIGNO  IITNTNCISEXTE
ENWHIS HE NGIG SNITOT  IIN
EXNCTEE HEYIS  ISA H, NGWEEAV
TOAK M WSUE REOTDOE  NANAV HE
AMANICTA GES.PO
LL SHETIHAAD H T CSAT ME
CN
T ABOUETSEA CR P
ICOLE.
EA14 YER LRSATEDKE, NN
WAY S
LLKIUM, EDTR H HANADUG EADNOH,
SD ANHEBOD,AI AHESHLI T
IA.
C TSOHE ACEONRNHEUTBO TIA C A
E
'EDNNY'SAS ASIOINSSATTESTN AR
M
ELDIMEATY, A AT P E THTO
OH
U.E S.OV GT,NMERENART  ISTDTE
ARTHWI HRY T
MARUN.
AN 5THD ENSYE8 ARWEERAT, EE S
NC AANGE ITHY ATREFUNG T
OCO
ITLYMP WLATHH E
LAWAS PAND SEUNY OUIMSL
BYCO
.RENGSS
EYTHAV HEWN BLOWO TINEA DDL,ES
WNOEE THR
PELEOP,HE TLYSIY MPTO  DNO
BEEVEHE TN IA C OISTH
QU
.TIESON
S ISTH IYWH TEDY HENEKEO  TMA
THMEDOE CUSNTC.UB PLI
TH H CE AVNOLIDIREBI
OTYN
'JFK'SAS ASIOINSSAT
WHITESE HOU CONRNINRTHG EIE T
REE.AS
EYTH PUT SUT O ANTTETAMEGAY SIN
TECOARORY D INNTUENESTPOPONTME
ARCENESSPR TYO ECOTTGA ASTIN
FIENIDTIRMLEAB AHEOFS  T
TAMILIRYEF DSEEN,
LAW
RCENFOENEMTTH OR UCCOE NDOFT
FOREIGREN S TILAONUCTHWI S
ITITAVY UT O TIGWEHSLI PHEUBGR
C
INRETEST
ESGUT:N WHE YK  LOUOOSE TATHE
DOMENTS A L YNDOU WK OOATTHA
ISAC REDD,TE K YOUW,NO
FIENIDTIARLEAB HHETOM  T
NAEFALON DSEEN,NGOT NHI
THINTHG  WATASEA RELDSET LASO
WE'OU WLD 'VETHMEARD
DONTIALENEFSE IBEHAF D ENA
ENRE
TASLEEDSYEO AR. AGO
I E ANARTEUYOT. THA
NOSEG INROATO  TTH OEV LEL
F
OUSERI
ESSNS.
E THERILY MASTBEL  TNGS
L
BETHG INWIROLDHE FUEA M TR
NAECALON SITY FORMINIOATN
THEOR RECT , DSBUA  IITS NYTI
TARCPEEN.GE
'I'S N00 1OT4,0 DTSUMOCENHWH, IC
INCONTHA TUEO CT RVEEA
NSIO.
HO:ST OST GURUEFFS  IJE
SOEN
EYMORL,KI TALNG AHEUTBO TEW N
SAK JFASIOINSSATMEDON CUSNT
EDLEREAS
MIKEN  IHUSSMAAC GTTSES,DOO
G.RNMOIN
CAOO:ER GINMOD RN
THISIMER VY T RTPOANT BJSUECR
ME.
ALWAI S RIE IVDU THEAY O
F
Y.NNKEED
TIQUES IONS- -N  WHIS BATTA R
CUE EF BORCADEFIL AMROST C
ER PTOOW,AMHE T G
INBLGEIN
STINDU WRYAS OROTHN E A OLEF
LI
METI.
NNKEY'E'URFAS ILTOE  C RIDAUB O
FIL CTRASOOS CT TBL GHEAMGIN
RYDUINST ATU FOR,NEEC BHESEAU T
ER LREITUNLYAL RF UT O O
.
QMYNSTUEIO G IS,NGOIA P
E
A,CI T I-NKHI - IAS W WNGDEONRI
S
RE THEHE T PLISIOSBIT TTYHA
THINE HA CERG OGATHF E
G
RYDUINSTWI KNOT  TNGHAEREYTH W
E
WEAPLSENNN HEKEYED
EASADIPPOMD REFRHE SNECE,ID D
THAAV HE  R PE OLIN
TIUTG
EDKENNY
WA AY?
:HOSTHAK, O TNKNESQUOU Y.
T:GUES C THEALR'LER'S HET,GH T
GA ILIMBNGY USNDTRRYS WAVEIG B
AN HINAVAN  ITEE THLA 1S'0'
THBUER WE  HDIILNG TELOTS,YHE
D FARABLMEINE COAX T
IOOVPRIS, NSANTHD  HAD FRE
A
,NDAS B.ALICLY
THEYERE KINGOFOT LS .ON MEY
IDENWH FTR CELASTOO OK P
ER,
WTHEYIVE ERDR A OENUTY TNDHE
OTSTLO LONOFS  M AEYNDY  THEREWE
ITRYVE BOUR TEABTT. I
DAN TNTY HEWARE TEDO HEINGA T
T
DING
K THI INEN RINECTRS YEAVEI , HA
NOVIENSE ENCEHA TTGE SUGSST
ZEGAORNIME CRIER WE
THE
LLINTE ATUECAL OHOUTRS
THF E
SSASSAN.ATINIO
DOI HIOU Y T TNKHET  FACCKJA
ILBYRU K LD LEATARSTEA HYVE
,WAOSLDND AS E  HWAMAN AT
REASPIE TOD  BAN OEDANRGIZ
E
GUFI,RE INK THIHE T
INSAASSSOFIOATN AREE L HYVE
WAOSLD IA SI OF ZEGAORNI
INIMCRE ENLVVOEMTN THTSEVE END
OF3.96
OTDOI  N THI TNKTHAAN ORGEDIZ
IMCRERG O TIZANED
ATSSSAIN TN IOOFSI PRES
.
:HOSTAR MINLOY U CTON CNE
U,
ARYOU .NEE XT
CA:ERD  GMO
INRNG.
S,YET  THAE  TISRUOUATWH Y
T
SADE, IDFIROCAL STAS WD EH BIN
I
OFINLLG  AOB BBYNDAC J
KKE
EDNNY,EC BSEAU JD K ACAN
Y
EDKENN GWEY REONGOI TL  KIL
L
CA
ROST.
ANDIDE  HSAOH,  NY  TO,HETE ARNO
GOILTOG  KLE, ' I'MNG GOIO T
HELLKI T
EYD ANTHCOER WE D ECNNTE
E
AGCHICA MAO FIROUGTHEI
RFAR.
ERTH IN THI PHEROTIBION
ANDO, SH WHEEN TSAY IDHA TT J
U
BY WAS- -ID FEL ADANRRGEAT, WH
IS H LT,EEOSVEARY LDWA
,
USBECAHENEE ITOFONR E HE TM WEER
ARTUG ENOVETOH  E OPUR LL
FFO
G THMEINHAKELI T
FISTL DECAS  ITESOABLU
BLONSPSIEHEOR F T KS.LIILNGYRE
GUT: IHE TREVINOS  EOFNCDEE
TH
ERTHOISE  N EVINCET  THA
L
ROCASTNVAS W IVEOLDNNN  IKEY'E'
S
ATSSSAINN.IO
ITS'' NMPSILYE. TOTRU
LEBUT S'T'UREPKE ON YE E OETH
WSNEHAND A WOIIST  G ONGN
O.
CT BUNOISTRASO OT N WDIHHITOL
00,0OC DENUMTSTHRO FM
U.
ICPUBLHE I
EA DD.
L FIDE DSTCARO H NIDOTEAV
NGYTANHI WO  TDONNH ITKEY'E'
SAS
ATSSSAINN.IO
HEAI SD,ER AFT T
ATSSSAINHIN,IO TERISS  V
D
NE.WS
Y NNKEEDMAS WAA NNBEN GI
GO
MAKE TOV MESARDSEACE
ITH
BACU.
ROCASTERAS W VPPDIY SANTOIED A
ABSEUPT NNT OUKEY'E'INKIS LL
GBE
ITUSCAE LIAD ME E MFEOR
DIFOULICT . HRIM
HEN  SADEEPEHO
FOR
NCRECOONIAILTITHIT WH EDUNE IT
UATSTESERNDDYEN KNEAPPE, RHINS
COS HISEND TNDM,ER AISHI TS HY W
K'EDNNY'EMS ENTES IEHA
HID,
USBECAIDHEE  DNVOT N IBAE ADCU
,
T NO TRIDUNG BHEAYGSF  OPIR O
BAE THCUMISSE CR
ISIS.
SODEHE T ITHA AT CID FEL
TRO
BEWAS HENDHI T ANAASSSSI
ON,
ATTH NAS W ATHIOOTN HE TIA C
T T PUOUTHTEAFR ESISS AAS,TINAON
ERT BUTHO ISE  NLCTFAUA BISAS T
T
:ST D WHYTHYOO U K TH
TEAFR ASE TLLHE, EA YRSETH
INSAASSSSTIOATN LILDS HOL
ATSCFAINTHN IOWIPL PEO
T:ESEC BHESEAU TNMOV GERTENU
VES HANEIDPRR OVRE AED C
BLE
XP EONNALATI
ABOUT I HACIE A  LBES ENNGYI
AI IKE S OD,N D ONE
HE Y
TTOLDST FHEIR LUT AIEBOHE T
INSAASSSIOATN,ND A LSIEAV H
ECHY
EOENWH PTE PLGENDS,IE A
ASARE  BD KETO AIEELVE
TO Y
ITHATCRNOS T ,IBEDLETHHE TN
O
WI UMEP  -TH-HE TLEPEN OPRE A
ARCHG FOANR NS AR.WE
ASE THRE S TONHENDRYTO EESUR I
E
WEUSCAE T O  DNO GVEHA ADOO
ATPLEXAN WN IOOFT HPENE
D.
WEAND A AV HE
CRSEET
LLINTE AENIGCENCGEYT THA
COTOUEINS  WHHOLDOCU
S
HEOF TR UR MDE AOFRE P, DESINT
E
SARER LATEFIN,  DOFNCIAE HE T
W.
EWHATE E LSAR GOPPELEONGOI T
INTHK TEYN HATHBEUS MT GID HIN
SOINTHGUSER SIORWOT, HEYE ISWH
WO'D'Y  THEMECO F.WAORRDF I
SO IITS NDUT C A DRY,S  THIYGU
TLLKIEDHE PNTSIREDE
IF IWAT SO  S, MPSILEYWH D
T
STAKE YMAO NYO RSEA TSICLDEAS
Y
OSTHE LDWA FE?IL
S ATTH IINMESOTHCITHG E OTCAA NN
EXN.AI
ETHIA C T HAS P JHEFKBLEMHEY
DOOT NA AV HE LEEDCRIB TTO SRY
E
LLND AHAHE TY OT AVE LO T
THDEHI, TH IATS ITREE ALTRIY GH
W.NO
STHO:HO WSPS  IREE SIONBL THE
ALTINAONVERC AHIS TWATC
R
MATHE ?RITEAL
GUT: THEWORKTHIT WH
E
ESENAGCIAGTH, E  ACIENES
RESU
OSPPEDO  TN SSPA OKY ANJF
RESRD TVEY HEHAEIN  ITH
SSPO, SIESONETHVERC AHISS PUT
THO UT O TETHC.UB PLI
T BUCHE THARESIVS  I
BIA G
RNGOVENTMEY,GE ANC WBUH ITA ETDG
UT AOFBO350 LLIOARA N YE
REEYTH ANGEA DLIAIT WH AIA C,
$1N LLBIIOGEARYE AY.NC
IN TTUT HASI TIOATN,HI AHERCSVE
IS I NOTSIA N POON TDICTEAT
NGYTANHIE O  TTHA.CI
TO THEON C TARTRY,
CHEIA
ATDICTESTH TO ONNAE TI
AL
CHIV.
IFDOHE TY ANOT N WELTOT  RSEEA
SOMEING, THERCHISVES
ITNO
OS IANMP TIOITN, NY HEDOE HOTAV
THOR FCEFOO  TENEE RCTHAW L
. E
HE T0' 199 'S, HN HEWE
EWREVI, OA BRDD U YOHA
ENPEDENDCYAGT ENCOHA TT  GDUL
O
TOIAHE T CI R  OFBDANAY S, W
EWE
S  TNTHINTCUDOMEILWE,  W
UBIT PC.LI
AND TNC AHEGETOHAY D Y.OM CPL
THIS NINDETNDPEEN
AUITORYWHOW N,  WH ICIS
E
CIA SAS H AFSEEN O IY.UNMPIT
COASSSRE PD SEAAW LHEOR F T
COK JFREUTS,RD BE T  ATHEYA CITH
WEIDSA, T O  DNOIKELFE L
THINEYG , LATAW SILWEO  WEOB
T
IOBEY
D TRP WENG ANTLOTHIT WH ,EM
BIAND NTN DEWE WLO ANGHIT THE
.
RECONGSSS AS PSE TLAA W,Y HEDO
NOONTWA TDE ABI
OK, .
:HOSTISHI TS EDRO FM NEONIS,
WE
EYRS- -VE STE
ERLL: GDOONI MOR.NGCA
IIE BELH  WVEITANISTH M I
NGSAYIS HE,  ISOLULY R
.
IDE WONE IFR  HMES HACOCROS
THE JILESAM FESSON CFENIO A
VID LEATEHI PIPLLS,
F  IE
D TINOCEOSE OES NAM
.
ESGUT:AM J FIL IS AAN M
IN
PRTH, ONI KINE H GOTUT O
LYCERENTCLWH, O HEMEAID AS W T
S
.SSSAIN
ATTHS E  HWAE E THONHOATTH S
TTH
IDPRE EST.
SFILE DT S OENONYVEHA A
INTNDPEENBOOR CROTIRAONHI OF
T
O Y,OR SHA IITS KN TRDO
OWWH
MA TATO IT OKEF
OU CLDAV HE, BN EDAS OEATWH H
SA, I HHI TNKD'COE UL
'VE
NELEARTHALD L GSTHE INSA HE
IR
DI ROMEA L TNGHEURERITATOFE
SAE THASIOINSSAT
OTDOI  N
NO KW.
OTDOI  NLIIS DBEEEV I
JUI STHI TDO WNKE NOOT N K
GHENOUERHE WTHOUE  WSHDI CLDRE
H
AT S
RYTO.
IOMENT JD NEBYILESAM F,ESSE  HWA
A PEORNI OS TIRAONR FIOFCE
IH
CIE A.
HE IONE  S TOFHEOFIOENR
S
THA TI MITENEFEDON BHOE,OR W
KNLL A AUTBO OBEALSWD HEREFO T
SSASSAN.ATINIO
TH BISE  AIGONIL FE
AV D
E ATLEPSILPHLIREHA TT WIINMAS
A
CT RNYEANSIO,WE AN NOID DD
TE
OFANE Y LAHA TT STK. WEE
HERSA S PEIN OONF REST
TO
REJFK ERARSECH
KHELOW NEA T ABT OURVE LEHA
LDWA BTHOREFE SSASE SAN,ATINIOES
WHSE  HWAAL CDLE IN T
HEIN
ATSTVEIGN IOHE TBUD OLA
F
STABIEORS TOUD.SW OAL
SO OMEFM  THEDINTCORAORY.
IGSTRA.HTU NEE KP HRI SISTO
I MN,EAF  I IS  SIMEPL TTHA
OSLD ST THIDPRE ESHYT,EN W
WOULYOU OMLLTE S
ODEBY
ERDIFFORT ENSTOUS IEABT HIM
?TH
A  IATS UEODGO QABIOSTN TOU
VIDADIPHI PLLRE TS,HES I
ATFOINRMATN IOTHOTAS H N
EEN
PMADEABLIUBC IMTOU H
: HOSTVEHAOU YY R  OAN.
HEOTR
NAJOURSTLIED TRI T
GEO T
RMINFOABIOATN TOU THE
INSAASSSTHIOATN THUGROH REI
M EEFRDOOR IOFNF ATIMAON?CT
EST:E  W
VEHA.
THE RSA CIPUNGUI R.ORECDSRTHIT
IOOAS W LORNGKI FNFORTION
ABTOUROIA C PA GAPANDIOEROPAT
N
G LVVOIN.WAOSLD
ISTHOTS  IANVER HERE WTILAON
EHA
S HVEADHECEIN T0' 199
'S.
IT OUR TNST  TUTHAOPE THPE
O
DIIMMESOELATY HTBL TO EAM
Y'NNKEEDA'S ATSSSAIN CN IOONA,
ON CID FEL WTRASO,PEE ERREEDAT
ACINT AGEINWOS RKR UNG DE
CARAOGM ED A SLLPEAM -- SPAPR
L
L,ND ALYE  WONEDEA LRNEN  ITH
LA 15  2OR0EA YRS JWT USHO
MU TYHEER WROCOE NTY EDLL BE
CIN D ANRU C TBYHE.IA
, SOESE THPRISENIDT DIL KLE A
S
RETSSE AIAMM IEDUTLYTE PNGTI
ET OUTH, TO SRYS BACU IME BTOLA
.
WE,LL D WHY THEDO TT?HA
WHBEWAO S NDHIT? THA
SU LMYAWITAS WNEES DIGDO T G
ET
QUHA TT , TIESONREO WHWEHE T
FIOFRSCE THAKNEWBO AUT T
HEOP
N.ATERIO
AND RN LWEEAAI AED FNTAMR OU
ABTHA TT,HEUT B TIA C
ALONSTEWD,LEND AWEHE TY
REBA
P EDCK U C TBYHERTS,O  S
HEOFT  T NTO SRYAMEREV CE O.UTLO
REY WHWEHE TS SS AETTINEGERA
OPPRANAGDABO AUTAL OSWOR BD,EFNG
N
AFTETHESISS AAS?TINAON
TH DISE  AT UMOCEN TONHE
LSPAMELAMRO PGRISHA TT LYEA HVI
DARE
EDCT.
ITOTAS W NSEEL REA
DTAORNT
,SOE  WMPVEHA I
RMINFOABIOATN TOU O CIAONRAPETI
HENDOU TEDCC AUSSISS AAS
T
STARE LILT.EC SRE
THE S  ITHM OBPRLEE. FWEAC
HO:IM JPI I HN GHSBTTUR,I-
MJIN  IURTTPISB,GH H
ERLL: IA W TNT IKNO OWI.CA
HAODYBY S RSK AEDEROBT. FFAN
EDKENNORJUY NI TBO AUTHE? CIA
POHE SKEN IIL MAL, ANITONY
ERVENOMB6. 1
T:GUEST OB RERY NNKEED,NIJUOR
THN SOOFFK R, HAS S
D AIE
EDKENNY, WASDIL KLEEENESY  BA
PICONSROCYRA FINWIM THWNIS H O
GO.MERNNT
OTDOI  NIFNO KW E HKE TASAL
DD
HE BS IEELVECLS HIUNE K WAS
NEBY EN ESMI IS.E THU.
GO,MERNNTN  A HASSAID
T
ATREPEVELYED OTHR EEA Y.RS
STHOWE:' HEART  NEXOMFR
VIDAD.
DAVID ISRO FMURIS MSO
I.
MGOOD.NIORNG
ERCALL:MOOO GD
INRNG.
I LIULWOD  TKEOSK AOPOU YR
N
ON AOA B SI T AMU E URYO-VEHA -
BO'I'REM SUAVOU Y H.REE AD
PH, ILANAR HTMS HO W I
A
LIURJONA -- ILAR
WAMASTN -FULLANAR HTMAS W
A
NAJOURHOSTLI WTHAI SD  C TATHE
AUATS  F.LT
ANK RYU YOVE
UC MH.
ESGUAV IT: H TREE ADTM HOMAR'A'
S
BOOK
I DNOO T AITEEGR WOFALH L T, I
E T BUTHE CTPIURNT PHEAIS,HE T
IOTUSIATN63N  I19KEHA TT
EY
WASN, IORHE T FAIS CEAGTNS, HIM
I E K INTHS OKBO INODGO O
THTH O,N ATCUAR PTIR LA-- ON
TN
INSEE TTHEOFG  TSISS AAS
ATD ANWHNEAP HPE
WHODYEN KNES''S EMENIETREWE A
TH
IM TE.
:HOSTVEE  WHAWE V AIEWHR O
D,ASKEEFOU Y RD ENERCEM,HIUT B
TNTWAED MKNO OWOUE ORAB
JK
, RUBYOUATWH Y IHI TNK
T RTPOANW  KTONOHIOUABT ATM
TAISTH S?GE
ESGUT: JBYK ACRUE S  ITHON MAWH
EDKILLAREE L HWAY VEOSLDE, TH
SU AE OSITN ASSSSI
TOFHE
ENESPRID
Y DIHED IL KLIM H
BYRUAS WSK AER AEDFT?
RDWAS.
ERLAS WYHIOL TD  Y SM,AY
D
ITARO  TSPIEJAE CKDYEN KNEHE T
F INPA OL.TRA IA
ISHA TT RUHA WT BYEDOU MTH
.
THAM BATEC,LIE KE Y W, ESHE
AS.
O NGYI TJAARSPE IECKEN K
ITHATEPA S PRUSTEOSRO.LA CIM
JA RUBA RAY N RISTP CEB,LU H
HEUPEA BT EO PE.
HIRISTBE FS D ENWAA
OG D.
HEAD NINFEO EL J FGSOR
KIE
EDKENNY WVETSHAOE
AND PI DHEESBBD SEBOYNE KEN,DY
ECPROSGAE UTORCRZENID EIM
REFIGU
TEI IND IERVWEN WOA MANEATTH K
A
Y RCKUB WL.EL
ESHTA CONE EDCT MH ROTHUG
MY
E.BSWEIT
SHEND HABECE D AANISINR  H
CL, T ANDCAY HEBEMEDSRI FEN
.U
BYAS W OWE SETN H.ER
HEED ASKO ER H TRRY,  HIMESH
T IDSA ISWAULID RICS.OU
I AEDSK, D WHYKI HIDE AL OLLSW
?
ESHAI SSK ID, AED H, HEID
RENOT LYALNS AUTR,WE BL W IIL
TE YOUNE TI NGHI,
NDT
K THIN A HHEADHO CE.IC
ESH SVED,AI E WBORYDYORKSOR F
SO
DYBO.
WJACKFOKEORD LEPER OP
D ANK THI IN T HHEADKIO LL. HIM
DOI HIOT N THA HNKE AD IC CHO
.
I WHIDSA, WAO ST? I
E SHI IDSA,  NDOOT K
WAS  AT MEE THTISHBU, T W.SH
A
S CEDVIONNCDIUB RY NOD TE HAV
A CE IKILLWAG INOS.LD
E ATTH H DD HATO
ITO .
ANCHIEJUSTRRE ICWAE  CENAMAN LL
I
M.T SIHI
HED, SAIU F  IYOE KETA MOCKBA T
WA IGTINONILL LL Y
E
E WHOL
ORSTY.
RLEAN AR WRET D DINODO THA
HEUSCAE ID DANOT N WNOTOT  KT,BE
EY, SOTH BEV NERUGROHTUB RYK BAC
TOTOHIASNGTON ES TFYTIO T
N PLEXAIE ATWH HASIDSA WHE T
STOLWHE Y.OR
,SO HEDSTE AYILN  IJAIEND A D
DF
CE CANE THR REARYES,FT AER
FOUR AEA YRSHEERFT T
ASINATN.
STHO:AT PTYN  ITINNCOECT.CU
LLEREL RTOINATG HA TT,UB
RY
D SIVITEOT DBYORAL KHYOV A -ND-
ENLAKILL,ND AOTHE S GHELL A T
INN ATRMIOOMFRIM.
AND HEENTH SRAAS W BSHINGGG
EWA
G GOS INEA RTOEL A ISET.LL
THE   ENSHEDDINTAN UELIMY.EA DTH
STHEYE D AISHS WAON D
GSRU.
GEALLEHEY,DL TSUM ROR WEER
OHONND JASONNS WDEH BINT, IY
ECABEUS H--E EEO PPLN I CSGRONES
ONIORUORPT
N CALKU YOTABO AUTT? THA
GUT  IISE  TRUYNATTH LNDO
N HNJOSODES WAUNRNV ITITIESGA,
SHIID SA ICEKK BBBOYER BAKAD H
MPENBE ID CALITEIO VINAR
USCO
UPTI SCHESEM, ANS JNDOH
A
R UNS DEIGVEINSTFOIOATN
R
AT.
I'CLNOS T ETR EAWHNNR HEKEYED
INS WAGOEETOG  K'JOP HN 'S-
P  KTOEEN HNJOSO TONHE T
K.
IT O  DNOIDE SEEVHACEEN T
TJO
WASOHNN S IDOLNVVE IN T
HEAS
ATSSSAINN, B I TENKHI H
KNNTNS ITAT  WLYHADHA
EDPPHAEN
ITHD ATWHS Y, AERFT
DSW OAL
WAKILLHN, EDJOD N SOANREDJ GA
OVHOEROGOT G THEETRNO ON
R
DO25, AFAY DS ER TETH
SSASSAN,ATINIOEE THRAFAY DS R,TE
TD ANINEE AHEGRD TTHAY THE
WOSTIND VEANATIGE
FID ND
WAOSLD ANE H KILED LETH
PRIDEN
ANSOHNN ERHOD OVVEER WE
RYSP
.IFECIC
W NE C TEDOE S OUTFFTICUPELA
OB
TOUD'SW OA'SOT MABESIV, TOU
SHIIASS AOC
ONTIS.
QVERY, CKUILY AOPPELETOTHT E
OVHE T GTNMERENZEEA RLID
E
CMOSTENVEONNIH TRT UTISS WATH
GUTDDI I
N ANDELODOBY
IS
ONRESP ABLSIE,WI WNDE
NLT
STINVEANATIGE INODYBY .SHE T U
O
NTRNVEMEVENV IOLT.IND  I
,SOY  THED CIDEDEHEATWH T
Y
WAO EDNT TNDFIE EF BORETH
IGVEINSTHAIOATN EVD ENUN BEG
FOREDYEN KNEEEAD H BND,UR BIE,
TH DECHEEDID TTHHAY D
ESO
.TILUON
ON D GUY IT ONE
R FONO
ONREAS
ETH WARN CIOMIOMSSFIVEN RIED
, BUT INOWAT S IBCRT ED.LE
PL SITIMYN' WAS
'T.
LEPEOPCOAY S, CYPINSRA
THRIST - OS,H-T' '
VES RY
, MPSILEASISTH HN  BEET OUTHGH
Y
IRON CSPEOY ACTHSTS.
ITHT ATNOS TE. TRU
POWEERSTS  ONTUTK  W AEE
R
ASTHE ATSSSAINDN IOAN D AID
LIVADOL PLF  OEO0010 PHAE,PL W
O
HIOU Y TNKPE HAPHOD,NE WAS W
REBLONSPSI
HEWO T
6LLPOS, O-70%0%
E
LEPEOPLLN  IDAAS ANDNWAT NIOE
ITRED AIMOONHA TN ONPEE RSAS W
EDVOINLV
ATHA TTIMETHER NWEE RE
OCO
CYPINSRA TTSORHEISEROL. IV
STINWAE S
BOCHNGDI S PL OOINVANSENYLA.NI
ISONOWAT S PICOT NSCYRA
STEOTHRISHO WUPAM CE MOIT WH
H
P OANNEWASOERN SOL INVTD,VE I
WARCE THCICESTUMANOFS  T
ATE IMTHEDRE CATHA TTEL BF.IEECR
N WITASSP COTONTHACIRY S.RIEOST
ASIT WACHE T FHEOFT  TR.AT MTE
DAN TER GHEO'ENNMT'S
ATPLEXANHIN,IO TS D GUY
IIT
YONALE,W, KOUNOE EO PPL
VER
EVBELIED I
THEYID DELOT N BVEIET  I
GHT
AFTETHE INSAASSSIOATN, A
NDOV
TIMEHAT ATPLEXANSN IOHA
GOS LENESBLRE CDI
WITHLL ANFHE T IMATI WE TGO
TINHE99 1S'0'ECAS H BENE OMEV
LE CE.DIREBL
SO TIC OHEFFEOL IATH
HRYAS
EDFAIL
DITSOEOT NINXP ELA
HA WT
ENHAPPNO OEDN MBVEER2, 2 13,96
ST WSOE  NL ILDOW. KOTNO
HO O MEORAL CLRO F
M
NEZA, ILSVLE
IOOH.
ERCALL:OO GINMOD RNPA CG,-S
N.
STHO:REOU Y AN. O
AGO
ADHE.
ERCALL:HE TIOUE QSTVEI N HAS, I
E ESDO HEDT PUCRCEENN I THE
RYTHEOECHE T SRVT RESEEIC
DEACCI,ALNTLY FEM ROTH LOIM
THIBENDHERE P'DESIN'S, CAR
ACLYNTDEALHO ST
IM H?
THE'E'VINOS  ETONCDEE RTUP SPO
.IT
PHOTRAPHEW, ICEY,NEITSS
FOVIICNS E
NCDEE.
'I'SNE OE THF OS TINTHGSTHA
MOPPELEEAK
UP.
S IT IUNFOUNRTATE ATTH
HA TT
Y STORLL SISTID.RO AUN
TH G WUYHOEDFF OER
T THE
,
ACRETRD ITNDERT HR TEA
OFLE
CTLGA AN.IO
,NO IONIST  N
NSSEE.
STHO:O  T UNIFISHP,YO IF
HD
AFLAX TS HEOC D, ENUMTS
E
WOU D ULYO
ARSTT?
GUT:ES W ILDOU SITRTTA WETHH OS
PR OANAGDAONRAPETINDARS OU
LDOSWAOR BEFAFANE D ER TETH
SASSATIO
ATTH IS  SMOE STOUPIUSCI
STH
G INWE
AV HE.
WAWHY CITHS E NGTRA YIAMO  TBL
H
ECRE IM O RCUN BAFTHTIG A
ERE
WAEDNNY SD?IL KLE
WEO LLTI DTNO HGOE AVA
ANEXPLOFIOATN ASHO W WDEH BIN
TH W ANDEYT HATHTRER WE NGYI
IE ATOCH BVEY TT?HA
SOFFJEEREYMON RLS  ITHE THAU
OF
ALEV SERKS BOO
BSS HIWEE ITIS JS.FAFKCTG.OR
THK ANYOYOFOU R URE. TIM
HADAHOY LI TYSO
OU Y.
NGCOMIP, UTHOW H ONT CEROUESRI
SPE ARRE TDIONNGO C
IDOV,
RTPALYULICARGHN  ILIMIOFT  OONCR
ESR OUGUT ISIGAATZMONAN,
ILL LK THEO RUT ABO
HT
HASHE  WSES ENDELDORWI, WN
"WNNGHITO J"RNOUALNUON CTI.ES
♪
UNANNOR:CEN -S CPAR YISOU
UNEDLTFIEROFIE VW OV GT.NMEREN